可以不懂人情世故
但不能不懂AI
hello大家好
我是牛哥
今天呢
我觉得要再次给大家讲一下Claude code
为什么呢
因为两点
第一点啊
最近这个openclaw又火起来了啊
之前牛哥做过一次视频了啊
呃现在又火起来了
其实呢呃
小白啊我真的不太推荐你们去去
在这上面花太多的精力啊
现在把Mac mini都给搞断货了
就是这个东西啊
还是有一定风险的
我建议你可以用
但是你一定要知道啊
它内部啊
到底是咋回事
因为现在已经有很多啊
就是基于openclaw
不能说很多啊
就是网上有数据基于openclaw泄露啊
导致的一些安全风险啊
这是第一个点啊
而且那个啊
好多都是
就是已经开始有割韭菜了
什么499去上门安装啊之类的
对吧这个提到上门是吧
小美如果是美女来安装啊
也是可以接受啊
呵OK
这是第一个大点啊
第二个大点
就是open
就是Claude code啊
咱们现在确实
最近更新了很多很多能力啊啊
配套能力咱就不说了
核心呢
还是因为它模型现在足够强了啊
我为什么把这两个事放在一起说
然后来讲这篇视频
就是因为
其实如果你用好了Claude code
你完全不需要openclaw
就是如果你懂的话
这种完全自我掌控的能力
可能才是你真正需要的啊
Claude code啊
虽然里面带了一个code啊
虽然它的官方定位就是用来写代码的
但是牛哥可以负责任地告诉
你一句
它就是一个智能体的原生的
一个SDK的一个集合啊
你也不可能不知道什么叫SDK
那你也不用关心
你就知道它本身就是一个很牛的
很牛的一个智能体
你基于它可以做很多事情
只不过呢
对大多数而言
这玩意儿
目前就提供了一个黑白的窗口
导致大家跟它交互起来呢
不是很方便
但是如果你带着这样的思路
你只需要借助帮助
把Claude code去调节到你的通讯工具
或者是调节到你的手机
那这个呢
事情就是很固化的
有很多开源项目去做
比如说甚至什么happy啊之类的
这些远程命令行
t marks都能做对吧
这个是比较简单
甚至
你让Claude code帮你写一个这样的程序
都是可以写的啊啊
这个问题解决之后
那剩下的就是如何让Claude code具备啊
你想要它去具备的能力了
那这就是完全可控的了
甚至你都不用去网上找那些skill
你自己呢
就能把这些事情全部搞定
那你想轻松地去驾驭这个Claude code
那你就一定要知道
它现在到底都有啥啊啊
本文呢做了一个简单的一个整理啊
我肯定不会带着大家去读文档啊啊
那关键的地方呢
牛哥尽量给你干货啊
那claude code里面你经常听到的
无外乎就是什么command skill啊
skill这个词
最近是不是就是太太太各种刷屏
是吧包括openclaw里面也在提skill是吧
啊然后再包括这个plug in啊
agent agent那个
时比较早啊
比较早呃
那个时候agent也很火
对吧那么我们把问题收回来
那这些东西到底是干嘛的
我用Claude code
或者帮我做一件事情的时候
我该怎么去配置它呢
那我们由浅入深啊
我们一层层来
那首先来讲就是command
这我称为最轻量的入口层
嗯最轻量的入口层
其实他你可以理解啥呢
他就是个快捷指令
我举一个例子啊
你呢有一个员工
这个员工啊
他希望就是呃呃
你你想让他去干活对吧
你想让他干活干嘛呢
让他去帮你去门口看看有没有人
我只是举个例子
他是你的秘书对吧
你每次呢
你都要跟他说这句话
每次你都跟他说这句话
你累了是吧
下回你就告诉他了
我给你一个眼神
你就去看看门口有没有人啊
那这个眼神
那就是command
就定义了
下次你再想做这件事的时候
你就不用再劳烦你的体力啊
上嘴唇碰下嘴唇叭叭叭说这件事
一个眼神
他就去门口看看有没有人
那把这种快捷的啊
等于一段话的封装
这就是卡曼的
一点技术含量没有
因为所有的现在智能体
都是建立在大语言模型
也就是LLM
大语言模型嘛
都是建立在这个上面的
那所以其实说万变不离其宗
最终玩的玩的都是文本
是吧就是利好文科生
我这么说大家理解吗
对吧那command呢
就是一个指令啊
你把它一封装就可以了
它所有东西
不管是command
skill啊等等这些东西啊
都是可以通过斜杠去
调用的啊
那它们的区别呢
有啥呢command一般只做入口啊
触发能力的入口
它去执行一些比较简单的事情
有的时候我们会封装一些agent和skill
大家知道skill有的时候是主动介入
有的时候是被动介入是吧
agent呢可能啊
就是主动的去去调用啊
或怎么样的
那command作为入口就会非常方便
你甚至可以在command里面啊
直接去做简单的这种编排啊
对其实他们没有太大的边界
就是能力越来越强
就是command的定义啊
你看典型实践是吧
哎你给我输入一下代码是吧
然后你去给我干干嘛干嘛
对吧大概就是这种
他做的事非常具象一件事
这就是command
然后下达一个指令是吧
你去看个门是吧
你去帮我那个赚100万呵
对吧大概这样
对
好agent呢
就是真正的执行者
对包括这个claude code内置呢
它也会有很多这种agent
agent就是干活的啊
就是其实agent呢
就是赋予了它一个角色
你可以这样概念
它会有自己的性格
自己的思考习惯方式或者倾向
是吧啊
这就是agent的一个定义
就是你会给他完整的
比如说
你让这个agent必须非常仔细的干活
还是说啊
非常简单
简明扼要的干活
那这个agent呢
最后执行下来效果就是不一样的啊
并且呢agent呢
你可以去编排啊
你可以让他做一些复杂的事情
说先做什么再做什么
当你怎么怎么样的时候
再怎么怎么样这样的事
情呢是可以用agent去做的
Agent它这里面其实也是一段文本
但是Agent它最大的一个好处就是
它引入了一个东西
叫做闭环啊
什么叫做闭环
是吧啊
就是说agent呢
要可验证的
就是你会告诉agent什么样才算做对了
这跟我们教人做事一样
说你必须看到什么什么什么
才代表这个任务完成了
哎这就是一种一种验证
那agent呢
就就会按照你给给的方式去做
不断地解决问题
不断地去解决问题
直到他看到了你给他的那个信号标
就你给他插的那个红旗
哦这就是主人要的红旗啊
他才会跟你说完成了
这是agent的能力啊
然后我们
如果你用claude code去做你这些事情
大多数时候呢啊
基本上agent就够你用了啊
但是现在的skill很火
我还是那句话
skill很火
是吧其实还是那句话
他们本身不分家
有一些东西啊
比较复杂的啊
写在agent里
写在skill里
其实原则上没有太大的区别
区别就是在内部执行的时候
agent呢
是可以用指agent这种方式啊去执行
那什么叫指agent
也很简单是吧
大懒支小懒
小懒干瞪眼啊啊
这个一层层传递啊
除了第一个你管它叫agent
直接跟你去答话的
剩下的全是SUB agent
这么理解就可以了吧
其实一点都不难
一点都不难
对那说呢
agent呢那我们就要说一下skill啊
我们跳过一些
跳过一些其他的东西啊
那些东西不太重
要我们最后再讲
那skill又是什么呢
skill呢就是agent
是一种全局性的描述啊
你怎么怎么样做
怎么怎么怎么做
再怎么怎么样
是吧那skill呢
是自下而上的啊
全局是自上而下的
那skill就是强调哎
怎么做好一件事情
我们刚刚说卡曼的时候就是做一件事
那怎么skill又是做一件事呢
那跟卡曼的有什么区别啊
对吧那牛哥告诉你
卡曼的是做一件简单的事
skill是可以做一件复杂的事
我举一个例子
同样让你做一个糖拌柿子啊
做一道菜
糖拌柿子
每个人做出的味道都不一样
那我现在就希望他做的这盘菜
跟你做的这盘一模一样
那怎么办
只能按照你的方法去做是吧
别人的方法不行
那你的方法是什么
那你就把它一行一行写清楚啊
我先切什么
切多大再怎么办
怎么放等等等等这些东西
那这个过程描述啊
这就是一个技能的描述
所以称为skill
对
这就是skill跟command的不同
skill呢会描述清楚
你就按这么干
干完就能得到这个结果
说一说吧
skill就是啥
最佳实践啊
我们经常会说这个词儿
最佳实践
而且除了啊这一点啊
其实command咱还是说比较简单
就是一条指令
skill呢还可以配合脚本啊
这个呢你现在如果要是听不懂
你就先不管它
因为大多数时候你也用不上
甚至说这些脚本呢
可以让让AI帮我们去写的
但是我还是要介绍一下
它可以配
套脚本这也就有些时候啊
AI执行一些事情是比较费token的
用脚本就比较快了
举一个例子
你有一张数据库是吧
里面有1万条数据是吧
你让AI去读不得疯啊
直接Tarkin干爆炸了是吧
你只希你只希望去看到
里面叫小红的男朋友有多少个人
是吧那可能你去写一个脚本
去连这个数据库
然后一个SQL语句就查出来了
直接就会给你返回一个数字
这样
AI就不需要看你这个数据库内容了
只需调一下这个脚本
就知道你这个数据库里面
小红的男朋友有多少人了
这就是啊
引入脚本的好处
主要是为了节省上下文对
和做一些其他事情
比如复杂的健全
有时候你要去登录邮箱
假设你这个skill是登录邮箱
可能还得二次健全什么的
呃用脚本呢
是比较方便的
因为脚本对标这种确定性的流程
那还是很好的嘛
在没有AI之前
咱们不都是用脚本干嘛
对这是skill的好处
再一个就是
skill呢是还可以往里面放这个引用啊
因为我们我们知道
我们知道什么呢
就是我们不能把这个一个内容写太长
你不能把一个百科全书做成一个skill
对吧那里面呢
它可能就是什么呢
就是它会有一些预定义
它说啊这个东西你参考这个文档
那个东西你参考那个文档
这样就可以按需的让AI去加载
这也是为了省TOKEN
明白了吧啊
最后最后就是典型实践有
就像你做一道菜一样
你还可以把它作为一个典型的
一个案例啊
也放到skill里
因为skill是个文件夹嘛
它有自己的文件结构是吧
把这些东西都定义好
就告诉他
典型案例是这个
等等等等
其实说白了
就是skill有了引用加脚本的能力啊
引用就引用那些规则啊
引用那些其他文档是吧
案例就是那个案例嘛
大概就是这样
然后脚本
那就是像刚才举的这个例子对吧
然后skill和agent的区别是吧
它这里面说是吧
skill agent是谁来干活
怎么干是吧
等等吧啦吧啦
skill呢干活的专业经验
典型事件
你可以说
那还是那句话
skill就是至上而下的
skill呢agent呢
就是至上而下的
skill呢就是及之下而上的
不知道这么说大家理不理解
如果还不理解呢
大家可以在评论区给牛哥留言啊
牛哥看到时候尽尽量呢
会给大家去回复的啊
然后剩下的这些巴拉巴拉巴拉巴拉的
咱就不展开了
关键词go
怎么怎么地
我们回头往上走
这个时候呢
我们再继续深入一下
以上啊就是你用Claude code基本上能够
或者用这种AI智能体啊
基本上能够掌握的3个概念就够了
对吧就够了
这是最主流的
最最主流使用的
那我们继续往下拆解啊
现在你可能还会听个词
叫plug in啊
就是尤其在各种市场market里边是吧
market place里啊
各种分享skill的
都是基于各种plug in等等啊它
又是个啥嘞
对吧其实很简单啊
这个东西啊
不是服务于帮你干活的
是服务于分发的
就是对防止就就
就比如说
总不能说我给你个skill啊
牛哥给你个agent
给你个commander对吧
啊每次让他给你发文件
或者这样你考到某个目录
这是不是有点太low了
是不符合咱们这个21世纪是吧
这个AI盛行是吧
这个工作方式
那怎么办呢
他定义这个东西叫市场啊
听过这通过这种Plug in的方式呢
去安装其实特别简单啊
你这种东西做完之后呢
可能就是一条指令
杠plug in install
我看这里没有案例啊
杠plug in install就能把它装上去了
这里面没提供案例啊
这个文档也不是牛哥写的
现在呢其实人要懒啊
就是什么事情都让AI干
这当然也是AI做的啊
我看到写的还行啊
总结的还行
总比对着空屏幕牛哥干说强
对不对
一会给大家找案例啊
这就是Plug in是吧
没啥说的
它就是用一种固定的文件格式
你看见没有啊
skill放这里
editor放这里
command放这里
跟咱们Claude code本身
那个目录结构是一模一样的
是吧然后把这个东西呢
然后定义成一个Plug in
点Jason完事儿了对吧
然后他就会按照哪个东西去
就比如说你skills下面会有一个
比如说啊love牛哥的skill
那你直接安装杠Plug in store是吧
然后这个Plug in市场的名称
然后再加上
后边儿skill的名称就装好了
一会有案例给大家看啊
那么继续深入
里面还有一个词呢
叫hook叫hook
刚才看这里面是不是也有hook
这里有一篇文档专门讲Hulk的
Hulk是什么呢
就是其实呢
就是claude code本身
这个SDK在执行的时候啊
执行执行
在适当的时候啊
你给它配置完之后
它就会去给你进行一个调用啊
就是直接叫hook
就这么简单
比如说它启动的时候
或者是任务截止的时候
大概就是这种啊
就是你想做一些前置啊
或后置的这个额外做的事啊
统一额外做的事啊
那你就可以用hook的方式
比如说你可以hook他每次命令
每次执行命令之前都需要说牛哥你好
你是世界上最帅的男人是吧
把这个hook作为他的启动
hook那你每次使用Claude code的时候
做一件事
他都会先说这句话啊
就是这个概念是吧
那结尾的hook也是一样的啊
每次都让他总结总结一下
这次用啊一共有多少字
举个例子是吧
啊开不开心对吧
这样大概就是这样对吧
其实hook呢
就是一种事件监听啊
也不管什么叫事件
就是这种关键点
做事的这到某一个点
你希望这些点啊能够调你
其实在内部呢
也就是一个函数调用的问题
你那个文件写好啊
然后给它注册上
裹脸上就行了
大多数人用不上咱就说了
你看他这提供的默认的hook对吧
什么准备修改代码的时候
写完呢执行命令的时候啊
提交PR的时候
大概的巴拉巴拉
你看有这么多是吧
各种各样的hook啊
这个呢大家了解一下就行了
90%大家用不上啊
然后以上呢
基本上就把这个智能体本身的东西
基本上就都讲清楚了啊
然后剩下的额外的呢
可能会还会有些什么tools和MCP啊
那这这一块呢
其实大家就稍稍去了解一下MCP啊
就行了因为MCP有的时候呢
呃在外部呢
还是有那么一点点用
我看它里面有没有写MCP的啊
如果没有
那就只能靠嘴编成了啊
嗯MCP简单来讲呢
就是有些东西啊
就是呃可以通过一个外部的方式
就是注册进来
不用在本地去写啊
人家提供好这个服务
比如说我是做微信的
我就可以提供一个m微信的MCP
这里边提供各种接口
各种方法
不管是什么
然后你一掉哎
就能登录
一掉就能啊
发言那大概这样
比如有two b
如果做个m c p
那我们AI基于这个m c p哎
直接就能去有two b发视频了
发评论了等等
m c p里面其实就一堆函数啊
封装了什么能力
嗯那我们就能做什么啊
大概就是这样
对吧就是人家把这些技能啊
或者方法都已经写好了
对吧然后最后还有个东西叫老色
不对LSP啊
不是老色批是吧
language Server啊
Protocol啊
这个东西呢
大家也不用太去管
因为如果你不写代码
你就不用管
如果写代码呢
就是更强的语音理解能力就好了
是吧这一块呢
目前呢没有太官方的一个说法
大家知道一下就好了
但是号称呢
现在也都支持了
包括open code也支持了
但我还是那句话
大多数人呢
更用不上
包括写代码
大多数时候你也用不上
除非你有一些特别的需求
你常规的东西解决解决不了了
你才有需要它
那大多数的时候啊
这些语言呢
已经是世界知识
AI呢比你都懂
对啊以上啊
就是本期视频的全部内容啊
那说了这么多
你了解了这么多之后
你只需要本地呢
去运行一个Claude code
或者基于你家的这个嗯
闲置电脑啊
运行Claude code
然后基于远程呢
你做好链接
剩下的你就配skill就好了
这样你远程下载质量
它就一直跟你干活了
比如说此时此刻
牛哥在跟你啊
巴拉巴拉说着视频
那牛哥的后台还在改自己的网站啊
这样这就是AI时代带来的是吧
一个人可以当n个人用是吧
OK这就是本期视频的全部内容
如果有任何疑问
可以在评论区留言
也希望多多支持牛哥
本期视频就到这里
我们下期再见